[Music]
I'm from Argentina and before it was
cool actually and um let me tell you a
bit how I started in this to get me
maybe an intro de centralized law so I'm
as I said I'm from Argentina which is
the world capital of crypto and I see
argentinians very much over represented
in the audience I see some familiar
faces and
we we are over represented because we
Liv in a country with very much failed
institutions and kind of crypto of
blockchains in general were a way and to
compensate for that right
so the question I asked myself years ago
was okay we live in this country with
this very much failed justice system
people don't have access to Justice
because it's expensive because it's slow
because it's corrupt in many cases can
we use blockchain to rein vent dispute
solution and can we use blockchain to
make a decentralized justice system that
can give people access to Justice even
in situations where the state Justice
systems don't work very well those were
the early ideas that now became claros I
know people know claros here how many of
you know claros oh oh a bunch of okay we
have a bunch of of people who know
claros um aiz Justice protocol it's used
in a different types of sit situations
you can use this for small claims uh you
can use this for solving web three
disputes if you have a protocol that has
um disputes between users like
e-commerce or freelancing Airbnb
disputes you could plug this to Clos and
Clos pick a panel of jurors and we'll
give you a
decision enough about
me um let's um introduce our panel I'm I
was going to just read your video but i'
say maybe why don't you just introduce
yourself so let's start by Kelsey um
yeah please um tell us about a bit about
you and why are you passionate about the
centralized law sure thank you uh so my
name is Dr Kelsey nabin I did my PhD in
Australia uh and my postop uh at the
European University Institute my PhD was
on resilience in decentralized
Technologies and I'm a social scientist
so I'm interested in these as these as
in decentralized Technologies as um so I
Technical Systems so I'm looking at the
human factors that kind of interplay
with the technology uh and my current
research is on uh Security in
blockchains as an example of security in
the digital
economy L zero hello everybody my name
is leer CER happy to be with you all
today um I am a Colombian lawyer and
legal is my background and I have been
like in the crypto Rabbit Hole since
2017 and at maker I started uh at maker
Dow three and a half years ago in a core
unit that at that time was called the
sustainable ecosystem scaling core unit
so we worked a lot about uh Dow tooling
operations Dow operations we had an
incubation program we run like scaling
strategies for the da which included
also like legal support and one year ago
probably many of you are familiar with
the restructuring process of maker one
of the most comprehensive restructuring
process in the whole industry as part of
that restructuring maker outsourced or
spin off its previous core units that's
what happened with our core unit now we
are called Powerhouse and Powerhouse is
an independent and and spinoff from
maker Dow and what we do we build
operational and legal infrastructure for
Dows in particular for maker da also for
our own team because we are structing
ourselves as a network as a
decentralized network organization so we
provide operational and legal
infrastructure RoR for our own emerging
Dow for maker and beyond my interest now
my biggest interest is in system design
legal system Design This what we are
building our complex systems you have
Wroten about uh cybernetics and d and
that's a topic that I find quite
fascinating uh because it's when you imp
when when you have these mind models uh
from system think from system design
that you can cope with all the
complexities that we are dealing with so
legal system design and legal
infrastructure for Dows and for netor
organizations is my greatest
hobby good um we have some I don't know
hopefully it's not the NSA interference
you know
uh it's it's your mic or
M H it's
censorship um well I don't know or it's
mine very good okay no it's mine yeah
yeah go
ahead okay awesome well my name is Eric
Alon uh finance division University of
Colorado Boulder I'd say in the broadest
buckets I placed my research into
constitutions Economic Institutions and
digital governance dilemas and people
are like wow that seems like a heck of a
wide range of things and I'm like it's
actually not even a range of things it's
all one thing and so for me ultimately I
view blockchain networks as a sort of
fascinating form of secondary rules and
digital contexts that productively
coordinate people's interests in our
increasingly sort of digitally
intermediated world and so for me though
everything's incomplete pursuant to
layers point about complexity and so how
these systems design ways to make
decisions in real time about the
unforeseen is kind of one of the central
elements of what animates my research
and Consulting work in the area and I
think ultimately questions of dispute
resolution and ideally Justice emanating
from that are Central to any kind of
vibrant governance system um over a
sufficiently large and complex human
group cool well let's get into it then
um so let's start by a bit uh what are
the core principles that you think
should guide the centralized law maybe
we can start with with Kelsey
sorry I was yeah giving eyes to the
audience just to sort of see who's in
the room could you please re ask the
question yeah yeah so what do you think
of the core principles that should uh
guide decentralized law yeah
so the way I am currently thinking about
this comes out of a working paper that
I've co-authored with uh Professor Ellie
Renny at
rmit uh and the the core tenant is that
security is fundamental to uh statehood
in in both the physical and in the
digital world and so the core tenant
before we can talk about decentralized
justice has to be Security in the
digital
ecosystem uh and so the work that we've
done uh it was an ethnography so um an
anthropological style study of a open um
open- Source Hardware uh chip startup
that calls thems a crypto State called
kland and we pretty much look at that as
uh providing an alternative to the state
by like through the provision of um
Hardware security with the open source
cryptographically verifiable chips that
they're offering and so we I'll get
nerdy on it and then I'll bring it back
so we used this the um the metaphor of
the stationary Bandit by maner Olsen and
I'm not a public Choice theorist which
is why I say metaphor but the idea is
that uh the the role of the state or the
function that the
holds is to have a monopoly on violence
and so if decentralized Technologies are
to be a better Bandit than the
stationary Bandit of the state that
takes taxes but provides basic security
in exchange then decentralized
technologies have to be able to provide
that security and so I said before that
my current research is on security and
blockchain and I've been looking at a
not for-profit uh organization uh led by
Sam czy son a white hat hacker and I've
been looking at how the actual security
audit firms the white hat hackers and
also the adversaries all kind of
interact and the necessary
infrastructure that's social uh
technical legal and economic to start to
provide that security in this land of
oneway irreversible transactions where
there are you know very big very well
resource tax
occurring um layer zero so what what
does this look like from the
practitioner point of view can you tell
us a bit about what technologies are
essential for enabling de centralized
law and a bit also about your experience
in the med governance yeah sure so I I
had like the privilege to experience
very directly the Pains of a large and
complex project like maker do it is
complex because not not only because of
the size of the project or the value
that is transacted in it but because the
governance surface or the actions and
decisions that the system allows to take
were very very broad very very wide very
open and to manage a decentralized
stable coin and not only that but has
the aspiration for serving the real
world economy requires a lot of like
complex legal structures in the real
world and take that into a governance
system that was one of the first crypto
projects to implement onch governance
and to implement allegation but the
governance system was not sophisticated
enough to manage the complexity of
decisions and it turned out that during
the the the be Market that governance
turned dysfunctional and you cannot put
like all type of boats to delegates that
have like a higher order like Vision
perspective and from that to the most
granular operational decisions if you
put them all of that in same structure
without any uh additional U structure
around it then it turns into
dysfunctional so it turn into um like
toxic behavior and paralysis and
politics a lot of politics like in the
real world and then this the project
started to lose money in the in the be
market then that's led to Runa the
founder coming back and restructuring
all all the governance process and part
of the restructuring is to divide the
operational um from the politics the
governance the decisionmaking system
from the operation of One technical
operation and to so those are very
fantastic experimental new type of
organization for some things but are
very bad on other things they could
they're great and Noble because you can
extend ownership you can Collective
governance over a Commons for example
they are democratic and open anybody can
access them uh without being
discriminated that is great but DS are
very bad at executing and
operationalizing so what maker in the
under the new structure is building the
structures that the da needs to let the
da do what da do well and Outsource or
spinoff and create specific very
specialized entities that perform
specific functions that any organization
needs functions like operations like IP
management like Capital location
fundraising commercial all of the these
type of activities that you need legal
entities that but but for very specific
purpos and we are designing this this
legal legal platform and letting the da
be da
this is a what I like about this space
that I mean we have these concerns about
technology and how to build this
decentralized tools but at the same time
we are still you know working with
people and you know politics is the way
in which humans uh do stuff in
organizations right so um and the right
way to put this energies of people uh
for a common goal is I guess through the
correct mechanisms right so they don't
become internal politics in fighting so
Eric is an expert and he has designed
lots of constitutions for daos tell us a
bit about how you see this centralized
law and how the mechanism that you have
to put in place for this to work and so
folks especially in blockchain
communities might well take my my
perspective on this question is hostile
to the extent to which we can Exon
mechanism design the actions of
participants in a particular ecosystem
and it's not I'm like the more we can
reliably and legibly do so heck yeah
automate that give everyone the
certainty in the way things will execute
and that leaves more space for the fact
that we can never fully program the
action space of the messiness of human
intent as mapped to any particular
algorithmic system but to me that means
there is always going to be a gap
between what you can fully design exante
and what you need to decide on as a
complex human group and so I know
trilemmas are very popular in these
ecosystems and so I view how you can
Define what good decentralized law
should look like as well as how you can
Define what good governance should look
like as itself a trilemma which is you
can't have everything all at once what
do I mean by that I think every good
governance regime should be ideally
representative Equitable and sustainable
and the fact of the matter is every
ideal decision should represent as many
community members as possible but the
will of the majority sometimes wants
awful things and so that's not to say
that in every instance that which is
representative is desirable sometimes
it's radically inequitable to do so so
there are naturally massive constraints
that you want to put on a majoritarian
decision in any particular environment
and there's a way we could tread that
line if we had infinite resources to do
so what do I mean by that well if we
could literally expend all time and
effort possible on every single decision
we would probably get it right in terms
of balancing representativity and
equitability but no group has infinite
resources and therefore we have to cabin
all of our decisions made within any
particular group by the constraints of
limited resources and limited
information and so for me somewhere
within that triumvirate all important
governance decisions should reside
although striking that balance in
practice is darn
hard this is a question for any of you
um and I B like there I see in this
space there is like this tension a bit
between we are building a decentralized
legal system for decentralized new
organizations
blockchain now they call them Network
states in the past there was a different
name
um are we building this for those new
organizations new communities or these
tools can interact and can help design
better Real World existing you know
communities whoever wants to pick this
hard question so the tension is between
what and what uh I mean do you think
that this kind how how how how are the
interactions with the real legal systems
that
exist I mean I I'll kick this off I was
just uh talking to folks that are trying
to do a popup Village uh in India this
morning and I think there's a real
tension which is Sovereign guarantees
are very very hard one from the
countries that have the best rule of law
and the best institutions not in an
absolute sense every country has its
problems but boy are there some places
that rep protect individual rights and
Economic Institutions in ways that many
many societies don't and not
coincidentally those are the societies
the ones that protect those things are
the societies that are the most
prosperous but good luck getting a
sovereign jurisdictional guarantee out
of any of those governments problem
being though is the more you try to set
up a network State a coordination you
choose your preferred nomenclature for
your particular startup society and to
me in places that are most willing to
give you jurisdictional guarantees those
guarantees are only as good as the
particular regime that is in power at a
given moment and so there's a really
radical dilemma is situated right there
which is is it a you know a startup city
in Wyoming which will fight so hard for
every last inch of sovereignty that they
obtain but those Sovereign
jurisdictional guarantees that they do
obtain will be much more likely to be
enforced by us courts than say currently
the ructions that prospera is
experiencing with respect to the onor
and government and so for me there's
there isn't a simple answer but that is
one of the critical tensions that I see
under Ging a place-based choice of where
to try to create a startup Community but
the question is do you need a fixed
location because one of the other
interesting margins that I'm seeing with
these pop-up communities is the fact
that some are trying to be ephemeral by
design that has a lot of benefits but
boy have human communities been defined
by a fixed geospatial location for a
heck of a long time such that that is a
fundamental trade-off with that
particular design Choice as well I think
that are slowly acknowledging this this
tension and do you see like the first
years of th was like this more naive
approach or the absolutist code is law
right and whatever output uh we have
from code then that should be legitimate
output but what happens if the system uh
this dysfunction or behaves in a
different way as designed then you need
that more qualified a code code
difference but a qualified code
difference principle that you could say
code has priority the system of law but
in certain situations we we want and we
need legal recourse and we need legal
entities like Legacy but what we really
in reality need and what we are working
in in the maker ecosystem and and and a
Powerhouse is to design hybrid legal
entities that have code Defence that
means they are controlled in some way or
another by governance of ADA and I think
that's the way of alleviating distension
it is an opportunity that we have a
whole new design space to design new
like hybrid techno legal Solutions
entities that are covered or controlled
by Dow or contracts that def that refer
to Smart contracts or to wallets or to
onchain Tools in this design space
because we know as you are saying we
live in the real world if we do business
if we want to offer a functional system
for the world we need to design
instruments that are compatible with
that with this vision and that are
practical so like very practical things
like how to hire people how to hire
contributors well we need an entity this
entity needs to uh sign a contributor
contract and you have to issue an
invoice to this entity so you can file
your taxes as a contributor from the
from very basic
operational functions to more complex
ones uh the um the the opportunity to
bridge this tension is in this design of
um hybrid um techn legal
tools and I'll add to that question as
well so I think that uh there's always
going to be an interplay between
decentralized infrastructure and
traditional legal
systems uh one helpful framing uh for me
to think about that comes out of
blockchain go a research group that I'm
part of that's led by Prima defilippi
and that's um the endogenous legitimacy
and the exogenous legitimacy and there's
ways to look at that about you know in
what ways does the decentralized polity
create legitimacy that pushes out into
existing legal systems and in what ways
do the existing systems impose on the on
the Pol
and you know one way uh that projects or
or people aspiring to to parallel
societies might want to think about this
is uh what parts of the uh incumbent
infrastructure can they actually take
advantage of towards their aims so for
example I was speaking um to a legal
colleague uh Joie pirovich yesterday and
she was saying you know people clients
come to her when they make um you know
when they're fished so they'll make a
very substantial transaction and it goes
to the address that they didn't intend
but the first response is to contact
centralized exchanges and ask them to
freeze the funds so that's an example
where you know we're saying decentralize
everything parallel societies blah blah
but then coming back to that security
fundamental you actually do want some
guarantees that your you know your money
goes where you in intend it for example
and that there may be some recourse or
accountability um structure or way to to
draw back on legal guarantees of nation
states or traditional Justice systems as
well we have also experien I me you know
this uh when we started claros in the
early days we were a bit focused on okay
all of the world is going to web three
people are going to use decentralized
nbnb decentralized you know e-commerce
decentralized everything and they will
need disput solution
I mean someday that might happen and we
will spend more time in decentralized
virtual world and metaverses but we have
learned that in order to have like a
real impact we we needed also in the at
least in the shorter term to address the
disputes that real life people have
which includes a better way of
onboarding them uh into and they don't
even need to to use crypto for for using
claros right you can use this with a
fintech app or with like we just made a
agreement with the Supreme Court in
Argentina in a province called mendosa
for them to use claros for as a
consultative way to resolve like
neighborhood disputes and real life uh
real people like kind of of situations
that can deliver better Justice um for
for this
situation so you're you're colonizing
the traditional legal systems with your
decentralized mechanisms it's a hybrid
design of thisp resolution systems
because uh I mean I mean I still think
that in the long term we will spend more
time in decentralized apps
and the I mean full early version or
vision of claros will be realized I
don't know how long it will take that is
a matter May of timing but and this
gives me perfect uh for my next question
I mean what do you think I mean what
does a world look like where
decentralized law has I mean been
adopted I mean what what do you how do
you imagine this world to
work so a world where decentralized law
has been adopted yeah it succeeded
completely I mean I it it it's I'm a fan
of decentralization but I think that
there's a a deep fan to be very clear
but I think that there's a common
fallacy that's very very human which is
We crave a perfect solution we want to
reduce uncertainty to zero and we can
never actually do so and therefore to me
every institutional solution is
imperfect and it needs to be tailored to
a particular context and there is no
single Silver Bullet solution and so for
me one thing that's often lost is
centralization has been emergent in
human social orders for a long time
because of certain efficiencies that are
wrought there from it also allows for a
lot of Oppression and a lot of
subversive outcomes to be very clear but
all else equal you know everyone needing
to participate in every single decision
for every single community of which they
want to be belong to or invest in is it
it it it Beggars the very attention that
anyone would have in a given day and so
for me something alongside
decentralization that should be
considered is another piece of
constitutionalism if you will which is
democracy is not thought to be
universally good absent constraints on
its exercise and so for me in and
balancing certain concentrated fonts of
governance Authority is another emergent
feature of constitutionalism that's
under appreciated and so I think a
vision of decentralized law that fits
those principles that I already
articulated sustainability equitability
and representativity a vision of
decentralized law that does so will be
one that has some pockets of
concentrated Authority you need an
Arbiter to resolve a dispute between two
people and that is centralized even the
mustard panels that claros uses are
centralizing briefly and in a very
constrained way a an authority over the
people subject to that particular
dispute resolution and so for me
separating and checking and balancing
any of those concentrated fonts of
governance Authority is essential but
I'd like to end on a positive note with
this point which is transparency is
tremendously valuable when it comes to
the exercise of concentrated government
Authority and so I think another benefit
of the extent to which observable
actions in these ecosystems are legible
to anyone that cares enough to actually
perceive them is a fundamental
constraint on any concentrated font of
governance Authority running away with
the ball that being said I'm also pretty
concerned about the extent to which your
average token holder doesn't seem to
even want to show up to vote or pay
attention to what's going on cuz boy
does that cut against the restraint that
transparency other whites provides if
those with power know that everyone
subject to that power is watching their
every move in that concentrated
governance Authority
context yeah for me the key factor for
adoption is
accessibility and we need tools open
source tools we need public goods we
need legal public goods legal
infrastructure so we have with
blockchains we have a system and from
the legal perspective is a system a
system of rules you can with blockchain
technology with smart contracts you can
design rules you can execute these rules
and enforce them all at once without an
intermediary so that's very
revolutionary this capacity of creating
normative systems and to creating them
in a way that are fully transparent and
automatically enforceable is quite new
and is what is driving all this like da
da movement nevertheless what we have
seen is that Dows face innumerable
operational and legal challenges and the
legal service industry is from the old
age we have a leg the Legacy legal
service industry is is proprietary it is
close source so we cannot all Ds are
solving the same problems but all of an
are paying Council and because council
is confidential you cannot share your
findings then this this knowledge is
lost we cannot uh uh we cannot allude to
the collective intelligence um and the
service the Leal Services industry is
for this new web three movement it is
out of date so we have with blockchain
Technologies with dii we have public
Financial infrastructure so the question
is what public legal infrastructure we
need to support the system and for us
the way is to develop open-source
templates open source templates we work
in particular with Powerhouse with one
particular that is called a document
model which is a system or format for
structuring data but structuring data is
can be anything or for formalizing
processes business processes and data as
a tool as an open source tool that every
project could could use and for the
legal from the legal area you can use
document models as open source tools to
automate to formalize and to automate
business processes and turn them into
Apps and through apps they they have
also a normative function because
through apps then enforce a specific
process or a best practic or at standard
so we use apps and and blockchain based
token and smart contracts to embed these
rules into software and to make them
available so that like legal costs are
prohibitive expensive and only large
projects can pay the external like
expensive external Council like small
projects that try to yeah and emerging
parallel Societies or network States
what type of legal um we need a
revolution in the legal world to support
this the system and there is in my
opinion open sourcing and converting
legal infrastructure into a public good
of course there are some limitations you
cannot do it as easily as you can do it
with software but we need a we need a a
second revolution in in legal to yeah
enable par
societies same question yeah um my view
is that uh wide adoption of
decentralized legal tools in the current
state of the world is very bad and I'll
explain why um because the trade-off is
on accountability on end users so
uh no matter how perfect the system of
governance is or the design of the
mechanisms you know the fundamental
flaws are in operational security that's
where most of the you know scams and
hacks are going on and so like seeing
behind the veil in you know um the
security Alliance has an initiative
called 911 which is like a first
responder Channel there's a bot you can
access it on telegram you can look up
security alliance.org to see how to
access that um and you know literally
behind the veil the the volunteers that
monitor that channel 24/7 are just
talking about how they're drowning in
tickets and you know the state of
security is not getting better in this
industry it's getting worse you know uh
and and you know they're doing their
best to Foster you know security mindset
of kind of absolute paranoia but the
accountability tradeoff of white
adoption here is on the end users that
don't design the systems they don't uh
they're not um accustomed to the same
kind of disclosures and guarantees of
traditional infrastructure but then they
can still be hard done by in terms of
using these systems and that's why I
think what you said about claros is
really interesting because if there's
use cases where claros is being adopted
as a very efficient uh and in many ways
legitimate Justice solution in um many
sectors not just uh crypto projects uh
there's still a fall back of the
traditional legal system for those
people but you know to our conversation
earlier today sometimes people won't you
know resort to the courts after a claros
outcome because they're satisfied that
they've had justice within a you know
very reasonable amount of
time I mean in our experience um we have
tried to cooperate with governments and
institutions to build better Design
Systems what I see and it happens a lot
in this space is that people see
decentralized law decentralized
governance as a competitor to
governments you know as a okay if we
build this people start using this and
then the other thing becomes Obsolete
and then you know everyone switches
which is in my view a bit I mean wishful
thinking because um the mid ball mid
World space will still exist you know
and uh governments are going to exist
and uh um I mean I I also have a bit
bias of okay let's build this I mean I
read sovereign individual I read you
know Network State and but kind of what
we have learned is that it's better to
collaborate and to see how claros and
decentralized Justice and decentralized
law can fit into existing existing legal
framework so this is my next question is
how do you see governments and
institutions are responding to
decentralized law in on its path to
adoption this is a question for the
lawyers at the on the panel whoever
wants to pick this it's I I always ask
hard questions you know I mean I it it
it's this certainly isn't a lionized
public governments but I think feder
Rico's point is an important one I don't
see them Vanishing anytime soon and so
at a sort of at a granular level having
helped to design some novel
organizational forms we actually had to
wave our council's professional
responsibility to us because they were
sufficiently uncertain as to the advice
they were giving and so judges and
lawyers are inherently risk averse and
it's baked into their professional
responsibilities if they're licensed to
practice in a given jurisdiction in case
you couldn't tell from my words I have a
law degree but I am not licensed to
practice in part because boy does that
give me freedom to speculate on novel
organizational design in interesting
ways but I think socializing lawyers
with you know the tech techology is
critical because Joanie perovich that
Kelsey mentioned is part of kind of a
initial wave of lawyers that are willing
to take the bull by the horns and
actually come to understand the
technology to a sufficient level to
where they have enough confidence to
actually give professional advice that
is within the confines of their
professional responsibility and their
jurisdiction and so I think ultimately
familiarizing and not being hostile to
lawyers per se is a really important
precondition ition on the government
level I think it's more a case of
convincing them of the value and the the
just the viability of certain
technologies that are emergent in these
ecosystems one the finality and
transparency of these networks is
something that they should and do value
in terms of ongoing prosecution of hacks
that are occurring you know over 10
years ago you can't pursue criminals as
easily absent a very clear digital paper
trail if you will in from A to B to zed
but it it in addition to that I think
zero knowledge proofs are something that
government should welcome because it it
actually enables the ability to prove
the truth or a characteristic of an
underlying piece of information in a way
that's mathematically certain and I
think that that has massive compliance
benefits that were only beginning to see
the cusp of their application of that's
a piece I have currently with Sophia Co
s also at eui and or actually also at
blockchain also Argentinian by the way
what's that Argentinian also Argentinian
a more important more important
characteristic to be very clear but I
think ultimately it's it's it's
embracing the margins of these
technologies that government should
value is essential to seeing their
adoption as opposed to moves towards
their eradication like we're seeing in
certain certain corners of the
governments around the world I think we
have to be build projects that work that
that are functional that provide value
and when we show the potential of this
technology the potential of this
new revolutionary organizational art
that we're calling a DA like Dao is one
of more type of networks and networks
have existed all through history we have
this you can see the history of M of
mankind as this dichotomy between
networks and hierarchies and it's always
a pendulum and it's always a spectrum so
networks are not new what is new this
blockchain technology that empowers
Network to come to the to the next level
but we are still very early and in this
phase of Dow Dow in its current state
they are dysfunctional there are like it
this was not really a problem of om or
da a lot of big Dows as as long as they
reach a critical number some say the
dumble number that was exactly the case
by maker when it reaches 120
contributors it started turning very
dysfunctional but why because we don't
we still don't have again the
operational and legal infrastructure to
make them work and after this first era
a like naive first stage of DS I think
we will we will receive we will have a
second phase of of mature projects which
also involved interaction with legal
entities but a smart interaction that
now sacrifices the values of the
centralization and the whole like
potential that we have with uh achieving
the centralization and the potential of
networks but also that rely on
traditional instruments upgraded to this
new world we seeing this tools like cod
Defence um to turn those dysfunction we
have have to turn those work again and
not only like a show of of toxicity and
speculation and shortterm mindness
there's a huge potential of this
technology and a lot is organization and
and and legal
challenges and I think one thing that
these sort of parallel Society private
order governance uh experiments can
think about is taking consumer
protection seriously within their own
confines and I think um I you know I'm
thinking about the security Alliance
like one area that they do collaborate
with government is on the um information
sharing and Analysis Center so they have
their own it's called seal ISAC
initiative where they're Gathering data
on the hacks that have happened on you
know people that have tried to
infiltrate projects as uh staff members
and so on and then the governments are
taking them seriously because they have
you know a valuable repository of
information that can help improve
security around so that's one way that
uh these private order initiatives can
actually yeah again push out for
legitimacy one thing I can say from my
experience um we have we started claros
in 2017 so we are like old here and we
have work on this a long time is that
there is a change in the mindset of
regulators you can see that because
Regulators are humans and then there is
also some I would say generational
change
when we started and we were talking to
them and telling them about this
decentralized you know court system they
were like what this this crazy idea of
you know citizen juries you know on
crypto you know but now and you can see
that there is adoption by institutions
but it took a long way of getting
legitimacy through teaching going to
conferences you know writing articles
writing a book uh writing papers so it
takes a long time because these are very
slow movie um you know institutions law
is a law is meant to stabilize Society
is meant to be what gives a stability to
social relations so it's not that you're
going to come and change everything uh
from one day to the
other and with this I'm going to open
the floor for questions so whoever wants
to come I think there is a mic there
that you can use yeah
so one of the questions I have is around
identity so in I think Eric one of the
things you were speaking to is the
trade-offs and our idealized version
versus when it actually hits real life
and security as you were speaking to
Kelsey so how do we actually have
Justice because we have law and then we
have Justice which is the Fulfillment of
law how do you manage Justice in a
decentralized network when the only
carrot and stick you have is being able
to to cut someone's wallet off which may
not even be tied to their real world
identity they can just spool up a new
one and because we don't have actual
identity properly managed on the
blockchain how do we actually
effectively manage Law And Justice in a
meaningful
way it's a great question and I mean I
think it's a massive design tradeoff one
that's understandably been wrought um I
think both due to technical limitations
as well as certainly deep concern over
liability given regulation in many
jurisdictions
but absent uh you know some type of
identity whether it be different
proposals surrounding soulbound tokens
you name it I think it it becomes it
very very difficult to protect interests
beyond the strictly economic or
financialized that may Define activity
on a given Network and so for me you can
you can discuss what Justice Means
between Anonymous you know fully
capitalized including to the point of
being a string of zeros and ones leading
to a ledger balance But ultimately for
more complex human associative purposes
I think that that leads to a very pale
version of Justice if any at all and so
I think ultimately it it there are
interesting solutions that I you know
I'm a I'm a doxed root node on the Q
Network where we are a dispute
resolution layer for certain elements of
that ecosystem and it's thought to be a
benefit that our identity is known and
so I think uh an understandable both
technical limitations on identity as
well as reluctance given Regulatory
Compliance issues makes it you know a
hard question but I think some of the
associative purposes that you see these
networks being devoted to are ones that
require some form of more you know it it
it permanent and dare I say human
identity my opinion and experience there
is like a continuum from Models where
you can have no identity at all and all
of the interactions are going to be done
through a token so you have a token you
can do whatever to other uh use cases
where you don't need an identity like
off chain but maybe my identity is my
avatar in this community and I mean I
can interact with the community through
I mean a proof of personhood protocol so
I need to verify that I am a single
person but I don't have to say who I am
in the offchain world and then I have
this identity and then I can prove that
I am from a community because I have an
SBT that represent my belonging to that
community so that is in the middle and
then for other use cases and when you
have my government involved and stuff
like that you might need real life
identity linked to your like uh profile
so for some cases we can just do the
token thing for other others it's okay
to do the pseudonymous you know identity
and others need real life and they are
fine I mean there are different just use
cases all good yeah I think I would not
underestimate the the potential of token
tokenized reputation systems to build a
more just identity solution and for
example in in in our case we are for our
for the platform that we are working for
maker and Beyond we are developing a
token that is called the proof of work
token and this proof of work token
basically proves ATT tests that you
deliver some type of contribution to a
public
good and if you if you do that tokenize
and it's non transferable then you
generate a start doing a reputation
system and then can use this online
attestation that you contributed so much
work and this work can have so much
value or so much cost that could be used
as a primitive for many other
interactions in in the system so token
it also has its risks but I think we
should explore um token ation system to
attest this this function of attestation
um which is critical is one of the core
like properties of asymmetric
cryptography this digital signature you
attest something and you tokenize this
attestation and then you can use this
attestation in other type of
interactions so yeah tokenize reputation
system is one interesting design space
thank you for the question for the sake
of time I'd say um the work that I've
done writing on identity was around
civil attacks um and the automation of
um attack and defense I did a study on
an organization called block science
that I also do Consulting with um that's
available in my GitHub and then also
Puja is around somewhere and is running
a workshop or a lightning talk later
today and she's thought really deeply
about identity as well yeah thank you
I'll just end with one comment um fed
Rico I think what you were saying is
that it's it's contextually dependent
right and there's no one solution that
fits everything and I think that's on
that's more honest uh because
administering Justice a lot of the times
is geod dependent
depending on the context because you
have communities and you have real harm
and you have who's going to throw
someone to prison right like that's
that's a question when we talk about a
monopoly of violence in a state and the
need to be able to have the ability to
create accountability you need to be
able to have accountability and on more
light cases maybe you have proof of
reputation because nobody wants to get
kicked off eBay you know um you that it
really it's really nice to have five
stars and you don't want 4.5 stars on on
Airbnb so when we're actually going
towards moving from this kind of light I
would call light test case Dow economic
to more Network State um how would we
ever be able to create a system of real
Justice when we don't have the ability
to control the Monopoly of
violence I I mean I have tons of things
to reply but let's give time for more
questions because we only but I can
answer later should we take all the
questions and then just answer what we
can and and take it offline there's two
more
so yeah maybe maybe you can do them and
then we will answer whatever we can good
idea ham of registry chain probably next
parallel Society conference we will have
a humanoid here with us as like a
Optimus or
something uh I wonder like if it's the
only person here who's concerned about
what's this humanoid policy around it
would be privacy preserving what's the
Newton power of of this
robot inside my premises and how do you
see a platform or framework to regulate
all these Frontier entities whether
we're talking about humanoid autonomous
vehicles and AIS what would be
reasonably doable platform or framework
to regulate them instead of waiting for
state to start regulating that and they
make a big mess thank you question good
question um really thought-provoking um
we're talking about very broad very
nebulous discussions here I'd like to
put a pin down on something that's going
to affect all of us and some of us with
less money faster climate change if you
were looking at any single area where
accountability and some sort of hard and
fast trustless society that can be held
across individuals and governments the
impact of climate change the way we
handle that the infrastructure for it I
would just love to put it in front of
you if any of you have had any thoughts
around handling that thank
you uh Eric you mentioned that
governance governments should adopt or
be uh amendable to zero knowledge proofs
for compliance reasons my question is
what's the pitch to governments uh for
that when they're sort of set up to a
just accumulate as much and capture as
much information as possible um and B
they're dealing with a populace that
don't necessarily value you privacy at
the critical mass and to have kind of
been battered into complying into into
giving up that information um sort of
what's the pitch where where's the
incentive for them to adopt
that so I'll take that last question
very briefly I'm actually giving a talk
pursuant to Talking to Regulators at the
shielding Summit on Wednesday and so
ultimately I think not all it it
governments to a great extent respect
privacy to the the extent it's demanded
by their citizens and enshrined in
constitutional as well as domestic law
and Regulation and so it's not to say
that they don't want to protect privacy
but it does come up against other
legitimate enforcement objectives in a
very very painful way relative to the
fact that most of our other rights don't
directly conflict with government
objectives and climate change is far
more than a couple seconds of an answer
so I'm going to punt on that one but I
would also say I do think industry
self-regulation is a massively important
bullwark in the cases of Frontier Tech
as against more ill-fitting and more
aggressive uh you know government
regulation and so I think for all
Frontier Technologies deposit some
measure of self-regulation is actually
really really really critical for their
survival r
large the clock here says 10 seconds so
if you have some final
thoughts before they you know they
decentralized law executes
[Laughter]
us
no yeah please you you finalize this
please thums up ending thoughts um help
us build the legal infrastructure that
Network organizations need together and
let's open source legal and disrupt the
industry to take us to the next
level good job thanks thank guys
oh
[Music]